so for this video i know monster hunter
is a video game movie and it's not
supposed to be taking that seriously
but it's so fun to point out everything
that is rightfully devoid of logic
i'll also do some light recapping to
make the video more coherent
so to get down to business the movie
opens with an intro for the monster
hunter world
and then after the title sequence we go
to our world
however the first shot is really
off-putting
the filmmakers decide to immediately do
product placement with coca-cola
on top of it not really making sense for
a can of coke to just be chilling in the
desert
you can argue that it's to establish
that we are back on earth
and i might agree with you but they also
put the text our world
right next to it as if we don't get the
message
aside from that we then meet our heroes
and they run into an electrical storm
that they think is dangerous then they
drive through some mcguffin artifacts in
the desert that when charged
transport them to the monster hunter
worlds the movie never explains why
these artifacts are there
so it just becomes a massive plot hole
and the movie doesn't bother to explain
it
in reality you'd think that
archaeologists would be all over these
things
it's not like they are hidden or
anything given that they are next to a
road
you have any idea what they are sergeant
davis i'm a ranger not an archaeologist
but anyways while getting transported
their humvee does a ton of barrel rolls
and when they land they all seem to be
completely fine
i know they are supposed to be resilient
because they are marines
but not a single person gets injured
from that
whatever i guess so after that they end
up running into a monster that travels
under the sand that is called a diablo
yeah and the first thing these marines
do is shoot out the diablo while it's
chasing them
under the sand but shouldn't they know
that bullets barely travel through sand
at all
let alone the monster having scales
after getting chased by the monster for
a bit it manages to flip their humvee
and from what we know before they'll be
fine
despite them getting geeted out of the
truck mid-barrel roll on top of someone
just chilling in the back of the car
so miraculously again nobody gets
injured
and obviously i know that it would be
lame if someone died like this
but still it doesn't make a lot of sense
also while running away i just wanted to
point out this one shot of the main
character completely missing the monster
great job filmmakers also i'll throw
this out now but the editing in this
movie is
cracked it comes from the director of
the resident evil movies
and during action scenes the camera cuts
like crazy
here's an example from later on in the
movie from a fight scene that has
cracked editing
to me it's just a void of logic from an
editing and directing standpoint
to make a movie like this but i guess
that's what you get with a low budget
and lazy filmmakers
so after getting away from the diablo a
little time passes and they run into
some big
spiders the main character gets picked
up and stabbed by the big stinger which
at that size
is basically like getting impaled she
gets knocked out and the rest of her
team runs away
but i'll just stay with her because her
team doesn't last that long
a few minutes later she miraculously
wakes up
which should be impossible if you think
about it
the amount of poison being injected into
her should be a crazy amount
given how massive the spider is and that
they're supposed to be injecting much
bigger creatures
from that alone she should probably be
in a permanent coma
on top of being impaled by the stinger
but she wakes up for whatever reason
just to be impaled again by another
spider
as injected with even more poison it
makes absolutely no sense to include her
waking up here but for some reason they
include it
then surprise surprise she wakes up
again and escapes the big nest
i won't bother going through the
logistics of her escaping
but you think that she'd be dead from
that much poison coursing through her
and the amount of blood she must have
lost from her puncture wounds
but anyways she barely makes it out
alive and there's some stupid stuff
about it
but the thing that pisses me off the
most is that when she gets away
she decides to cauterize her wounds and
not the massive stab wound from the
stinger
but some random scrape on her ankle i
guess this movie thinks we have the
attention span of a seven-year-old
zoomer
and have forgotten that she's been
impaled twice
and they even showed us in the shot that
she is bleeding from her wounds
also by the way during this sequence she
has a really weird moment with this ring
and praises it like golem from lord of
the rings but i don't think anyone is
really here for her character at this
point
after praising the ring and cauterizing
her ankle she then decides to climb up
the mountain to look around
like what how is she able to get up
there in her current condition
if she is barely able to get up and walk
she is in no way able to climb a
mountain
ah this movie makes no sense
moving later into the movie she has some
conflict with a native that is marooned
in the area that she is also stuck in
they go back and forth fighting for a
bit until she rescues him from some
spiders
and she eases the tension with a
well-placed scene of product placement
for hershey's
that alone is pretty cringy but since
this guy isn't from earth
he has no idea what chocolate is and
immediately becomes obsessed with it
i don't i don't have any more he
basically turns into that fish from
spongebob who goes crazy for chocolate
chocolate chocolate
[Applause]
but yeah totally this moment is really
weird because this badass monster hunter
turns into a little crazed kid when he
tastes chocolate
i know chocolate's sweet and all but
surely there must be something in the
entirety of the monster hunter world
that tastes sweet but i guess not
this is his first time tasting it
anyways
after these two characters start to
communicate they devised a plan to get a
sack of spider venom
to then use on the diablo to pacify it
but the plan is completely devoid of
logic
so the main character ends up baiting
herself and draws out one of the spiders
the issue with this is that all the
spiders can come out at night
since they are sensitive to the sun
because of that
the fact that only one spider comes out
to try and kill her doesn't make any
sense
especially after they end up killing the
spider more show up afterwards
like where were they before i guess it's
just oddly convenient that only one
showed up in the beginning
but besides that let's go back to the
execution of the plan
the main character must draw the spider
into a trap by running over to it
the issue with this is that the spider
just happens to be much
much faster than her to get around this
the filmmakers show us in one shot that
the spider is right about the catcher
and then in the next shot the spider is
suddenly farther away
to me this was very noticeable and
reminds me of that segment
from monty python and the holy grail
where the guy is running towards the
camera and he keeps teleporting back
whenever the camera cuts
on top of that stupid aspect there's
another one in the scene
when she ends up getting the spider to
the trap she then gets cornered and the
spider tries to impale her with its legs
but somehow the spider misses like 13
times
despite the main character hardly
dodging at all
but yeah this sequence to me is the
perfect duo of showing off plot
conveniences
and plot armor after that point in the
movie it essentially goes full blown
video game
zaniness and the main character trains
and becomes a monster hunter
to help take down the diablo because of
this it doesn't feel like the movie
takes itself very seriously anymore
this is also hammered home by the fact
that they have a cheesy training
sequence on top of a mountain
so it's harder to complain about the
different aspects in the movie by that
point
but to point out some highlights of
stupid moments later on
we have the main character being the
best rodeo champion
in the world additionally
she gets imprisoned at one point and the
lock is inside the cell
that she simply just breaks open with a
chair
more plot armor even more plot armor in
the form of surviving a helicopter crash
while being tied down
and even more plot armor from the
characters surviving an explosion
and slamming into a metal wall i don't
want to go into detail about all that
because the movie didn't seem to be
taking itself very seriously anymore
the first half of this movie to me is
much more annoying
and then the second half just goes full
tilt towards guilty pleasure craziness
because of that i feel like it's more
justified that the movie doesn't make a
lot of sense
because the tone of the movie evolves
but regardless though i hope you guys
enjoyed the video
and let me know in the comments what you
thought about the movie if you watched
it
or if i helped you dodge a bullet then
you're welcome i guess
you